[Música]
y en directo a América llegó el momento
de hablar de economía pero yo le doy la
bienvenida a mi compañero Jorge Hurtado
Jorge qué tal Muy bien Andrés Jorge
iniciamos hablando del colapso de
silicon Valley Bank la mayor caída
bancaria en 15 años en Estados Unidos
los organismos intervinieron y
embargaron esta entidad en una
sorprendente caída para un prestamista
que había cuadruplicado su tamaño en los
últimos cinco años solamente el año
pasado valía unos 40.000 millones de
dólares silicon Valley Bank se convirtió
en el mayor prestamista estadounidense
en quiebra en más de una década tras una
semana turbulenta en la que fracasó en
su intento de captar capital y se
produjo un Éxodo de efectivo de las
empresas tecnológicas sus mayores
depositantes el departamento de
protección e Innovación financiera de
California alegó falta de liquidez e
insolvencia el colapso de este banco
comenzó después de que thunderfulness y
otras empresas de capital de riesgo
advirtieran a sus empresas retirar el
dinero del banco silicon Valley Bank
estaba muy expuesto a la industria
tecnológica y pocas posibilidades de que
se produzca un contagio en el sector
bancario similar al caos de la crisis
financiera de hace más de una década el
colapso de silicon Valley hizo bajar las
acciones de casi todas las instituciones
financieras en Estados Unidos acciones
que ya habían caído de por sí dos
dígitos desde el lunes el banco tenía
unos 209 mil millones de dólares en
activos totales en el momento de la
quiebra pero tras la quiebra hay quienes
lo ven como un aviso de una probable
crisis financiera y por otro lado a
quienes adjudican su debacle a problemas
internos y que no se extenderá al sector
ni al resto de la economía Jorge vamos a
conocer Los indicadores empezamos en
Wall Street que cerró la semana con
pérdidas superiores el 4% en sus
principales indicadores arrastrado por
el pesimismo respecto a la seguridad de
los tipos de interés en Estados Unidos y
también el inesperado colapso de van de
este banco silicon Valley Bank hubo
pesimismo también en Europa ya que los
valores financieros lideraron la caída
general del mercado tras la ad por Esta
caída del banco estadounidense y en
América Latina por segunda jornada el
índice es sampimer Val de la bolsa de
comercio de Buenos Aires cerró con una
caída del
4,49% Jorge el presidente de Estados
Unidos Joe biden y la presidenta de la
comisión europea se reunieron para
hablar de la disputa comercial
transatlántica sobre los subsidios a la
economía verde y es que en Europa desde
hace meses ya aumenta las tensiones en
torno a esta histórica ley de reducción
de la inflación de la administración de
biden que defiende la fabricación
estadounidense de tecnologías que ayudan
a combatir el cambio climático a Europa
le preocupa que este Made In América de
la subvenciones perjudiquen a los
sectores energéticos y automovilísticos
con sede en el viejo continente y para
ello están trabajando ya en sus propios
incentivos como el plan Industrial
Greenville para promover el sector
emergente El presidente biden y la
presidenta de la comisión europea Úrsula
Legend acordaron que ambas partes
iniciarán conversaciones sobre los
minerales críticos utilizados en los
vehículos el la ley en disputa ofrece
430 mil millones de dólares en
subvenciones a los productos fabricados
en Estados Unidos y busca hacer frente a
la crisis climática y fomentar las
energías renovables pero Europa la
considera una ley proteccionista bien
seguimos ahí en Estados Unidos porque
hay una disputa por un contrato que
tiene Ford con una empresa China para
fabricar baterías eléctricas Sí de hecho
ya varios senadores estadounidenses se
oponen a que El fabricante chino de
baterías cald acceda al dinero de los
impuestos que financia la compra de
vehículos eléctricos como parte de su
asociación Confort el senador
estadounidense Joe Machine que redactó a
propósito la ley de reducción de la
inflación aumentó la atención sobre cómo
se aplica la histórica legislación y
quién puede beneficiarse de ella Ford
defendió el acuerdo con cal y dijo que
será propietaria de todas las
instalaciones estadounidenses donde se
fabrican esta batería y que nadie más va
a recibir el dinero de los impuestos de
los estadounidenses el acuerdo de Ford
con Cat forma parte de su estrategia
para aumentar la producción anual de
vehículos eléctricos a 600.000 vehículos
para finales de 2023 y más de 2 millones
de vehículos para finales del 2026 las
acciones de Ford bajaron un 2,5% en las
operaciones de la tarde Jorge en febrero
el mercado laboral estadounidense siguió
sorprendiendo con otro mes de fuerte
creación de empleo bueno Esto podría
suponer cierta relajación del mercado
laboral en Estados Unidos y llevó a los
mercados financieros a bajar las
expectativas de que la reserva Federal
de ese país suba los tipos de interés
medio punto porcentual este mes algunos
economistas creen que el informe mixto
aumentaba las posibilidades de que la
economía evite este año esa temida
recesión y en su lugar solo experimente
un crecimiento más lento en el segundo
mes del año se crearon en Estados Unidos
311.000 puestos de trabajo 206.000 menos
que los creados en enero en un momento
en el que la reserva Federal
precisamente está observando muy de
cerca los efectos de la subida de los
tipos de interés en el sector del ocio y
la hotelería
representó un tercio de los puestos de
trabajo creados el mes pasado añadieron
ahí 150.000 puestos la mayoría de ellos
en restaurantes y bares pero el empleo
en el sector del ocio y la hostelería
Sigue estando unos 410 mil puestos por
debajo de su nivel anterior a la
pandemia Por cierto muchas gracias por
la información económica y ustedes
televidentes también Muchas gracias por
sintonizarnos no se desconecten a
continuación una semana en el mundo
quédense con nosotros
[Música]